I don't want a drone coming outside my
window it's that simple if you have a
drop point for drones to deliver goods
and services fine if you've got a
package leave it in leave it in the back
but don't come up to my window knocking
say are you in can I come in
no plus these are airborne things
there's got to be a limit to how much
they can carry there's there's physics
behind this all right if you carry a
light box with a thumb drive in it that
someone ordered fine but suppose I order
a weight set suppose suppose your drone
is not carrying that my dumbbells okay
suppose you ordered you know a
five-pound bag of sugar the or if you
built the drone strong enough to carry
heavy groceries it will be loud and
large I don't see that happening if I
see a drone outside my window I'm
shooting it that's I'm sorry and I've
never shot a gun in my life I would buy
a gun just to shoot the drone that shows
up outside my window I don't know what
kind of cameras on it I don't know where
it's from I don't know
no no do something else with your drones
but don't put them by my window
you